i have just finished filming the arcane
video which is why i look terrible but i
want to ask whether arcane or piltover
and zorn
is a dystopia and this is this is willow
she's been locked outside all day
because she's annoying when i film but
she is here to join us and she's going
to provide incredibly valuable
commentary aren't you
uh so i asked you guys if you thought
that arcane was like said in a dystopian
and 75 percent of you across the board
said either it is or that zorn at least
is a a dystopia and i get it i i do get
why why you feel that way i do think by
the way it has dystopian elements but i
couldn't quite get it across the line uh
to to say like it's a full-blown
dystopia or it's a dystopian story and i
i moved away from kind of calling it
purely a dystopia one life is pretty
terrible in zorn
okay that's that's undebatable poverty
addiction you know strife being brought
by drug lords usually not hugely
positive things in people's lives
uh and the government brutally repressed
its citizens when they tried to rise up
and demand better living conditions
that's the scene at the beginning of the
series
and you can easily draw like parallels
to the hunger games you can be like
literally all of this happened in the
hunger games and that's clearly a
dystopian stories how's this how is this
any different
well
here's the thing
here's why it's not dystopia alright i
can't get past the fact that piltover
clearly demonstrates that it is capable
of change from within all right it shows
that it is capable of reform and
recognizing its issues and addressing
them from within the system the whole
ending of the series when the council
gets up and votes to let zorn be
independent uh is them doing that
they're able to have like a real
discussion about it this is much more
akin to like a society with some
dysfunctional problems that will address
them in time it needs to talk about them
a bit more uh or they're still debating
it but you know that doesn't make a
dystopia it's what makes kind of the
whole ending with jinx blowing up the
tower a tragedy it's because they just
got what they wanted this is that the
society had just settled its issues and
of course everything's just gonna get
worse now because they killed everyone
um
and that's that's the sort of
shakespearean
uh tragedy to it you know i tried to pin
down you know what actually makes a
dystopia and it's really hard okay like
defining any genre is incredibly
difficult i just kept coming back to
this feeling that dystopians are
permeated by the sense of there is no
coming back from this we keep making
these mistakes and this is where we're
headed and there's there's no reform the
only way to get out of it is is
revolution or total societal collapse
you know
and and zorn and piltover don't have
that all right they they just don't i i
couldn't think of another dystopian
story where like they peacefully reform
it from within even when you look at it
definitionally on its most basic level
that it's a broken world a broken
society uh its capacity to look at its
issues and try to reform them is in one
sense kind of like it being a
functioning society it being
like
the rest of the real world
it's not so much acting as a warning
panim from the hunger games had to be
overthrown there was no reform from
within
uh big brother is eternal there's
there's no stopping it there's no
there's no
uh reforming it there's no collapse it's
going to continue like this forever it's
a cycle and we're all trapped in it
because we let it get this far and it's
horrible and awful never let us get to
the position where it get where it ends
up like this you know
but
secondly dystopia
is a literary term it's it's
hello hello hello it is a literary term
right it is it is a term for it for a
sub genre but it's it's describing a
thematic vehicle it's describing uh a
particular
method of delivery of a type of theme
and message no people are wrong when
they tell you that it needs to be said
in the future it needs to be science
fiction it doesn't it just needs to be
clearly you know a warning sign for hey
look where we're headed don't let it get
this far if we have like a fantasy
series where the wizards created giant
magical bombs that explode in the shape
of mushroom clouds and they let them get
out of hand and they all went to war
with one another and annihilated the
entire world and created a dystopian
society in the wake of it
come on like
that's clearly warning us about like
nuclear weapons and stuff like that
the message is clear it's still
absolutely a warning and like yeah
technically you can look at any society
that is broken if you draw a line you
say hey this is what it means to be
broken where it has severe flaws and
injustice and problems and you can say
this is a dystopia but i feel like that
robs it of
any real meaning because you look at
game of thrones and it's incredibly
unjust and awful but it's not a dystopia
it's not a helpful description of the
world it doesn't let us know what the
story is about really uh it's it's it
just it's just not something that helps
and these terms that we use in literary
circles they're about helping us they're
about helping us define stories and
describe stories and articulate stories
and so we don't use the term dystopia to
describe just societies that have
incredible issues
but can reform them or are just flawed
societies but what does broken mean what
is what does flawed mean right and
that's why it also feels really weird to
me when people say hey the united states
is a dystopia or north korea is a
dystopia
because
uh
these are again literary vehicles for
meaning and north korea are in the
united states they're not they're not uh
they're not vessels for meaning they're
describing the real world almost
inherently dystopias exist in contrast
to the real world
and that doesn't mean that like um every
part of the real world has to be worse
than the thing you're describing in a
dystopia uh i can think of a number of
stories you know brave new world um
even hunger games that technically
speaking there are there are places that
are worse out there than than the events
described it's it's the contrast and
messaging that makes it a dystopian in
many in many senses
in north korea you know it's not a story
written with intent it's it's a tragedy
of the real world but you know we have
other terms for things like that we have
dictatorships and failed states at the
same time that doesn't mean that arcane
doesn't comment on the real world that
we can't take things away from it it has
a lot to say about power and technology
and you know poverty but
uh that's not the same thing you know
all stories have some meaning of some
kind but that doesn't even if it's
saying like hey these things are wrong
about society that doesn't make it a
dystopia
so
the last thing that kind of came to mind
is that a lot of people have brought up
you know i asked you know what do you
think a dystopia is is this one people
said you know it's the appearance of the
dista of the the utopia and piltover
looks like a utopia it's wealthy in
progress and and it's cool right it's
beautiful and i get where you're coming
from
but it's it's it that that's not a
requirement for a dystopia does not have
to have the appearance of a utopia um
and that is really a more recent trope
or actually it's quite an old trope but
it's something that at least
newer readers tend to associate with the
with the genre a lot more you know with
things like the giver and and so on in
summary the mere existence of injustice
does not a dystopia make however it does
have dystopian elements all right you
know it does have things in common with
dystopias and i think that was
purposeful it draws on in in many senses
the same fears and worries and concerns
that we have in the modern day uh as a
lot of stories do and so you can draw a
lot of parallels between them which is
what i was doing in the previous video
um on arcane you can draw a lot of
parallels about uh what these stories
are saying about the real world and
you're going to find crossover between
dystopian and just like generic science
fiction or fantasy
absolutely
and i think that's what we're seeing
there so that that that's my thoughts
not dystopian has dystopian elements uh
but again
genre it's all fluid right it doesn't
make sense
things can be whatever we want them to
be